helping the injured police officers fund
yeah yeah
and i want to thank them for everything
that they have done along with the clark
county school district police officers
all the police officers in town that
have helped without them this definitely
would have not
been possible we have been here since 9
00 a.m
and we have given out we had bicycles
until a few hours ago we've been giving
out bicycles shoes
clothing toys blankets
food we had a replenished probably two
times already
um mindy's at the store right now and
she's getting more toys which she's here
right now
so we've been we've had people in line
since 6 a.m and it's actually wrapped up
and we were able to service
over 2 000 families today and as you can
see
we gave out new clothes new toys
shoes bikes blankets
food food to families you know cookies
and um hot cocoa and um these families
are not gonna have
the christmas that we all typically have
and um we're just happy to give back
absolutely and let me give back and we
there was a lot of people that are
working that just got called into work
and they requested if we could come out
another day and mindy made it so we're
coming back on sunday yeah
we we have such great sponsorships that
have come together
along with all of our law enforcement
agencies um
our greater realtors throughout the
valley
um that stepped in neil sach mary from
nevada point mart
you know love him dearly and um the
better business bureaus that come
through
i mean this is about you know
christmas for kids but this is about
christmas for the community
right now and as you can see it's
we're almost finished but there are
still a huge line there that we're
probably gonna extend till seven
um and we're just so excited you know
what i mean she had coronavirus
and we were all praying for her to get
better and when she
came home from the hospital her husband
passed away
yeah and she's doing this eric lloyd
right here yes
so you know what actually this was one
of those missions every year
and uh we fed um families
um during the thanksgiving holiday and
christmas
and because of kobe we are not able to
feed those families
and our outreach today is just again
about giving back
how to clothe them feed them and you
know a lot of these families they
haven't had brand new stuff
that you and i are able to buy every day
and you can see oh look and i just want
to let you guys know mindy is my hero
for her too out here no for her to be
out here doing what she's doing
oh and her husband this is everyone
angel
and mindy you're amazing i love you i
really really appreciate everything you
do she's amazing and she always tells me
not to mention her
so i'm so glad how are you like
when did you come out we were so it was
so cold this morning
and that that's the weird thing about
this whole thing it was so cold today
and look how long people were standing
in line
we've had such great um police presence
all day long all day long all day long
and they've been
such great superheroes about it so
thank you so channel 8 is one of our
great you know sponsorship that we
recently got selected by channel 8 and
we're so grateful for that
so um we'll be seeing you a lot we
we just wish everyone a great holiday
and if you could share
something from your home just to make it
better for
your neighbor or your just someone that
you know does struggling
just be kind and be loving
the gift of giving this year especially
during the pandemic anything you do to
help others
is amazing because we all been through
so much
and you know we just wish everyone a
happy new year
and we're so glad to get a you know
smiles on people's faces
i want to say thank you for everything
this is a tremendous event that we have
in
this community and
once once again we do this
because we love our community the
communities right now is in
great need so that's what we're doing
because god is love we got to give love
to them
and this is part of my heart for
everybody